hello hello how's it going I'm not John
Luke he is actually back with just busy
because of GDC stuff GDC took took my
jean-luc away but that's okay yeah so
I'm substitute again however the fun
thing about this will be that at least
Ben gets a salty runback true so get
ready for that this time with new
weapons their new that everything with a
new update I guess I can make that
weapon though i I've got you've got it
got it can make the first ok I'm not but
yeah stoked about it
so we've got a new monster and we're
here to hunt it and you can join up with
us here the under under below us is our
session ID join up come hang out and
let's go hunt a giant angry pickle
together yeah we are going after the new
monster devil Joe is in the game now and
so so worthy like weapon updates and the
weekly event stuffs also and so we're
gonna probably do like a little warm-up
on something easier stuff right we like
to we like to stretch our legs
yeah we've it here we've got some other
event quests going on too outside of the
new monster which is a thing do you want
me to make this weapon it's up to you
that's fine it's not very good I tried
to make sure I had some of the new stuff
so at least I like look at it but I mean
I I jumped on that so you don't have to
ok but I want it to be fair later or are
you just gonna use the different fares
whatever I'm good with whatever we're
doing or is this thing for ready to go
to work good to see you guys good to see
you too and everyone else on the chat
also I'm real stoked
this ain't cheap man I have most of it
okay I have a lot of this stuff except
for the scale right yes that's a toss in
the bin for you basically that's I'll
make it
let's see here so we've got I'm reading
for equip it greeting the gluttons which
all the people all are all the monsters
that eat and are gross oh yes and a
gathering quests and in the event side
so that's I think we gonna start off
with this one cuz it's it's the low
ranked fight we get it done to get it
out of the way
yeah one sec as people join in
I got a did you upgrade your Deuter at
all
I haven't gotten a gym yet which is the
the saddest thing I love I love how I
hear your voice through this guy's mic
yeah that's that's what happens you know
I don't know I just went to my room I
was just such a scrub it's it's it's all
good
Sam I posted up the quests you can you
can join it whenever you get the chance
okay
oh I can just do it anywhere yeah grab
my food this is gonna be the easy like
whatever quest cuz sorry I should
probably eat to definitely because there
what up bro Dameron it's good to see you
too got the the the devil devil joes
there pickle boys that's fair I like the
guys X was it Fenix believe so oh you
you can hear everyone talking again IV
tanks alright okay yeah yeah yeah I can
hear everyone yeah yeah I got your
actual son said that I said that he
betrayed me when really he didn't betray
me oh so I take that back and I
apologize that's fine that's fair that's
fair V Phoenix there you go that's fair
I'm not you know what you're right
when's the restart got money to burn
after after we clear through everything
well we'll hit deviljho we'll do the
race on him to this post here I don't
have to be in the gathering up for that
right no you don't have to I'm on my way
to a boat a post aboard a cooling
aqueous old board available quest these
good to see readings yeah greetings
greeting the gluttons they're real real
big boys and they're ready to fight see
I think when you guys are ready we'll
head out regardless if we have for him
and we'll do it that way it'll be a good
time good old time we go now we got we
did we both did it already
Phoenix he's saying it's hard to find
double Joe if you don't if you haven't
done it yet but we got it the other way
is if you just kind of keep cycling
through your expeditions cuz he shows up
like as a question mark so if you're
struggling to find him that would be the
easiest way oh looks like he made the
devil Joe he's great sword that thing
supposed to be pretty good it's got like
the highest base as a great sword
it also looks pretty cool to be honest
the only problem with the devil Joe
stuff is it all has like negative
affinity yeah I'm not a huge fan of
misleading title that's not true we're
gonna get to him he's coming the main
course exactly we are you can't just
jump to the big thing right away yeah we
have to all the other new stuff it's
like a car you need to start it you need
to warm it up you turn the key and then
you race and then you go and it yeah you
just gotta you gotta get time I just hit
the partner oh we're good
I mean like if somebody wants to join
after the fact go for a session ID is
below our picture-in-picture join up
come hang out hunt a pickle yeah hunt a
giant pickle a giant spiky pickle yeah
he is an aggressive boy though he is
definitely he takes basel geese and like
just literally throws the ragdolls
I don't remember him being that intense
before augment and get rid of the
negative infinity that is true crime
however I still feel like for force
which akka switch acts at least that the
diablos acts is better even with the
augment just because it has a higher
base and then you get the element lists
but I think like the hunting horn which
I was telling Ben about is like
apparently very amazing cuz like you can
get defense up large health health up
large and attack large I should be quip
shouldn't go for the chamber straight
away flash you going for the jacket us
yeah where's that where's the third one
isn't there supposed to be three of
these guys she probably pops out of the
door I know he's up top he's just
dropping down oh don't worry I'm uh
I try to oh my god they're all here and
I'm just hitting all of them don't worry
Jagger's is already down it's you really
yeah
well then I won't make quick work of
this he's doing a murder I'm just an
invite us
rock steady no problem although I don't
have I didn't sharpen because im a skrub
I really should
this acid it looks pretty cool though
yeah I'm down with the aesthetic it also
let me change like my armor color all
the green which I'm very into oh don't
mind my casual reload sometimes you got
to get that reload great hey at least
I'm getting some of my investor my
bounties done yeah right I'm gonna make
sure I don't miss these these carves you
know cuz they're very important to get
these these lowering lowering carves I
went to look at my inventory just to see
how much crap I haven't sold here let me
just open up come down here you need you
need to calm down but I had so much
stuff to sell that I don't know I don't
know what I would do it with all but I
haven't tried that many weapons to be
honest or actually wanted to go great
sword or duel sword at some point but
yeah I kind of want to play a duel sword
- I got the the duel like exploding axes
and I just never kind of came back to
them other ones yeah they look really
cool oh look Sauron is here the Eye of
Sauron and we found him his body not the
eye my bed I was like where did your not
using a clave how is this guy not dead
yet
or the rock is that is a dragon a turret
it ready yet I don't know we kill him
with that I know if we can make it
through this fight without the dragon
ater I don't know man that's all I
wanted him see you later
you know what's all wrong you look like
you're having too much fun get flat oh
no no fun for you we want to have fun to
be phoenix is saying he highly
recommends the great sword yeah great
story got buffed his last update which
is why also I want to try it so I did
the long like a bunch of weapon updates
out there but yeah say I really want to
relearn how to frame the great sword
just because the the fan-created ones
coming oh that's some prey the rock it's
our one rocket great hammer and I'm very
into that great sword sorry I'll be that
guy
once it's fine soul offense about
getting this game J Murphy that's that's
fine you know what if I was good oh it's
books I saw for 45 bucks although
somehow that wasn't a fire like sorry I
perused the slick deals yeah times time
and I was like Oh 45 bucks seems cheap
and then like it wasn't it didn't have
the fire next to it which I was like oh
I guess it's not that good of a deal
because everyone who already wanted to
jump on right away has gotten it and
people are waiting
maybe 30s when a lot of people are
looking to go but it's a good game
though yeah but I will say it's not for
everyone yeah there's definitely some
people that just never really could get
into the combat and things like that
night I can respect its it's a bit
awkward cuz you kind of expect like a
devil might cry but it's not entirely a
devil my cry and I would say once you
get to like endgame endgame you really
want to have to see like you you kind of
want to have to grind a little bit to
get the decorations assuming you want to
min/max yeah yeah I kind of really have
to like like I really I still don't have
a critical boost gem I still haven't
gotten a second attack gem but then
again I'm not like super high level or
anything I haven't gotten a second
attack gem either yet I think I was
watching the stream where they first
showed deviljho you know with Capcom and
one of the guys says he has three attack
gems and I'm just saying oh great luck
to use what universe but I also don't
know what hunter rank he is because I'm
only like 70 something and some people
are like in the hundreds and hundreds
yeah there are people who have gone way
off
Pascal Myers asking switch axe tiaras no
we're using double Joe's both of us
currently but normally I use the to
switch axes I use primarily are the
Diablos one and then I also use the new
your gig ante one but I've been using
the Diablos one now that I've been
fortunate enough to at least have two
expert gems
I've also augmented it so there's a
little bit less negative infinity but
I'm also I said I need to get the
handicraft three necklace but you either
have to do all the optional quests yeah
or you have to do get to a high rank our
hunter ranked a hundred to get that
quest and I'm like that's so far away oh
look it's black spider he's back for the
race so I'm using I'm using a handicraft
necklace yeah I can't get it upgraded
though because
I haven't gotten the Jim I need for the
next level no I might be an eager Gant a
almost positive I had the problems what
oh no it's a loop in windy dragon I just
a windy I just got kicked from your
thing that's not good I thought we fixed
the internet thought we fix the internet
- oh we did what do we what do we even
do mannequins oh we got I'm gonna well
you're getting back in I'm gonna look at
all these these sweet new weapons that
everyone's got but the charge blade over
here looks really nice I didn't realize
it looks like it has like the the
chainsaw sword kind of kind of style to
it which is pretty good invites get back
in there see if it works
boss brown sugar says yo Eric you
playing see if sleep at all nah you got
me I'm rule oh you've been though yeah I
man you wish there were more get stuffed
- in that game where's John Luke he's
currently shooting a GDC thing so in his
stead you got me it's true but we really
want to do this this blue barrel
tracking like oh those are the only
event quests on I think there is a arena
quest to possibly which would be very
immense all right it's all good
I believe I failed to join late session
I can send you another invite send me a
hot invite oh wait do I have to go full
camera for this I mean I I'm not too
worried about oh no you're doing it from
there yeah that's fine I thought you're
gonna go back to your like - no by the
way they're adding new bounties in like
an hour I think I thought those were in
am I crazy for thinking that the limit
of bounties I think those are entirety
they might be possibly you'd have to
check at the bottom but yeah i think i
think these are new i think cuz like
when you log in it's like hey
there's you know here's the things fight
the angry pickle [ __ ] we could do that I
said let's just jump onto that I mean
yeah that's I don't get into this one
feel free I just have to make sure I get
back in for the race Yeah right I didn't
spend ten minutes before this dream get
make aired I want to say this save it I
can't show them yet all right I'm all my
hard work yet it's all good I'm not
feeling about this though well about
what like sorry what do you have a bed a
bed feeling about a bad feeling in the
sense that like I'm not yeah nah dude as
in like I'm not connecting you should
just start something up so you can play
with those guys figure it out here I
want to try try the wee-fee let's let's
start up a good old let's jump right
into the devil it's a pickle some
pickles some real real real getting a
real pickle over time better warm up
before the waiters drop now I'm fine I'm
fine all right so I guess taste trying
to get back in so I believe this one's
too free for all like you don't do you
don't worry you hopefully you guys have
done it before if you haven't well
you're in for a treat you're in for a
tickle
no cuz it rhymes with with pickle yeah I
don't know what else rhymes with pickle
oh he will be
yeah I'll try no the words that rhyme
with pickle are good words I'm gonna
trickle into this session in a second do
it do that thing I'll see him in the
meantime I'll read chat though that's
for sure
angry pickle yeah he's pretty angry
there's no doubt in that oh we got a
full full salad whoo so what do you
think you're gonna see like a higher
like a tempered version of this guy like
nice so far from the like I don't know
five to ten times that I've killed him I
still haven't gotten like an
investigation firm yeah I haven't either
I think oh I actually I got some
investigation
the last time I fought him but i havenít
to check yet temporarily you're just
getting all sorts of locked out see if
this store even works for me it'd be
interesting if they found a way to make
your save data kind of go cross-platform
for when the PC launches I don't think
they will I'm actually not too sad about
starting over cuz I really think it's
gonna force me to use a different weapon
oh yeah I have it at my disposal now to
like use another weapon but it's like
hey you know I'm excited to see the the
opposite genders armor sets oh yeah
that's right I can also go female hunter
because you know we both made a male
hunter yeah so there's definitely that
I'm it'll be it would be a good time I'm
down to kind of start over again and I'm
sure it'll look and run very well on the
PC hopefully and I'm gonna be a good
time I'm not too bummed about starting
it over your bi is next Monday I was
totally thinking there was no way I was
gonna restart destiny to on PC and I'm
kind of glad I did it was it was it felt
a lot better actually I crashed over a
minute I know but but the PC just in
she's really old of you just like the
mouse and all that stuff it was all good
stuff yeah and happy that they got a got
a chance to play at the PC demographic
that is yeah but happy early birthday
bro Dameron later horse mango see I was
good hanging out guess you came for John
Luke dang I know exactly where he pops
in now yeah he doesn't always show up
here right away though just kind of
annoying I can't join this session
oh he's slippery it's all rainy excuse
me oh yeah you got that combo yep yeah
oh he's got the charge blade yeah lookin
real good black sweater I should
probably make that charge boy just
that's really cool looks really cool
reminds me I like the whirligig saw from
blood-borne yeah
all right maybe I can try joining the
session ID manually
yikes I totally blanked out except they
don't happen
get this going
also happy early bday row Dameron
we're yeah well I don't even understand
where I'm fighting him right now I
didn't even know this area of the in the
middle
tweener area it's got a ramp on it
though I'm way into ramps he's gonna
jump off of this oopsy you say yeah oh
oh just barely boom Shakalaka
running away he failed me he's got a big
tail but his tails not that big not
leaving oh well do it fantastic that
makes me even more happy I like it
alright let's see if I can manually join
this loop real awkward that I can't just
join in general so kid can you wait for
like the time when we actually like all
the Internet's just sorted no it's
supposed to be sorted like right now
even the port in here I already had it
like modified oh dang and still not
working so we'll have to investigate
it's only it's his first day what the f
is this that's deviljho listen he's a
big monster
he's been boy kind of a pickle yes
hyper-aggressive he will if we see
another monster you'll see that he'll
pick him up he's everything yeah toss
them around
what's up monster the otic whoo I like
that we all have just like stuff from
the new monster equipment like oh you
and drag improvements all nice yeah I'm
as well just try out all the settle gear
ah kinda Oh apparently your session
doesn't even exist anymore really yeah
that's enjoying it because that's what
it says
real weird what did we do last time oh
look it's a great jagger as' you know
they're gonna get eaten probably I'm
gonna bet
oh it's okay I've come prepared for such
an occasion get cleansed oh no I still
haven't really felt the effects of that
like was it like take more dragon damage
isn't what it is I think so
and there I've seen him Shane the the
breath like six times in a row I'm not a
big fan of it I wouldn't be either
oh he's tired oh come on missed or I
typed it in correctly let's see
- at snow that's right
trying to get that that tail cut yeah
I've only done it a couple times
he's pretty annoying yeah you know I
didn't really look at it until just
recently too like yesterday was fighting
him whew oh hello you don't she's got
some real real weird proportions like
it's a body to leg like setup is he
skips like day yes there are so many
numbers he he makes sure that he gets
his his jawline fit
he gets his uh gets his tail done right
but his his arms and feet you know not
so no time mat so much he who controls
the pickle controls the battle it's true
those are wise words I'm really
surprised he hasn't like picked that
thing up you up yeah but I think it's
cuz you guys are destroying we're
hitting him too hard
yep it's like the jaegers wants to get
eaten these che say hey hey this isn't
there so ghosts to eat me supposed to
eat me and throw me around I can't
believe this care you're going off
script you can vine trap him yeah he
like all the places it was all I find
you do it nope nope it's gonna run away
again he did not care online sesh search
for a sesh I really should just join
your squad or something do you have one
of those I got a few of them got a
Master Hunter Mondays one which is great
cause it's on Fridays now that's
hilarious
cuz I heard that's a pretty reliable way
of getting it done is via the squad
squad squats ahem there we go
this is good that that's always not
gonna answer that Bob this is what
happens when pickle Rick stayed in his
pickle for him yep he got legs legs and
walked away and a huge tail and dragon's
breath
and like a spiky mouth jaw thing man the
great Jagger's is finally winning for
once I feel like yeah right he isn't
getting picked up at all no didn't a
just a cheap fighter and once around the
world
Ryu was a couple weeks ago a soccer will
be I don't know exactly what I don't
know if they put a date on soccer yet
and then they're also in street fighter
as well but you have to kind of have
done those battles and whatnot they've
got like a weird month-long plan for
that stuff yeah can't join this thing
not even with your sash I just saw
someone get in so it's got to be still
there so you're saying it's me I mean
maybe you try resetting the system or
something if realize it's super
desperate I mean I can do mine yeah
yours
I should probably heal myself maybe like
oh I'm just kind of cruising doing my
thing and then I didn't realize at half
health Oh
tail tail break yeah yeah yeah casual
car right in the middle of two monsters
is trying to eat us
hey you two go fight it out while we
carve this tail boom I was a great drag
race material here two days if you need
a I do you know oh there it goes
ah he's living up to his gimmick we got
it Oh double wyvern tear though wyvern
women it's all all good great Jagger's
like nope all right it's like Oh God not
again try restarting the old ps4 I can't
join either zazz toughest shoot good
glad it's not just me but that soon
you're draggin proof mantle is ready
about time that that side-to-side attack
seems way more intense than it ever was
to you would have a better idea that I
do is my first time seeing the angry
pickle but what's your how's your
impression your first time seeing him I
feel like because I've been fighting all
this other scary stuff it wasn't too bad
however his hitbox for like everything
just feels like big in terms of like how
he can hit you yeah so it feels like
it's kind of hard to dodge but I mean
I'm also just fighting him for the first
time so it's like you get used to it a
little bit yeah like that move is super
annoying the one where he kind of goes
sideways yeah sideways the sad but you
know I haven't fought like a tempered
version so he's also got that that range
thing where he like scoops a rock up
rocket at you yeah he's not even the
ball or that the DL stomp
yeah he's got the sumo stomp to where he
lifts up one leg don't you think that
the server is full
anything's possible that could be a
thing I don't even think about it don't
know I just know that we all race at
some point hekia not worried about this
part well we'll worry about that later
we'll have to fill the room again but
that's fine oh I don't mean I can't even
get into like his like Lobby I'm not
talking about this game like were like
his this hunt rather rocks he tried to
do the right there
call it out oh okay yeah I'm into it
also when he actually did the like one
really bad move to me the one that you
never want to get hit by where he scoops
to you I thought he was totally gonna
like you know throw me into the ground
multiple times while and his jaws yeah
he does it once and I was like oh the
attacks rooms
monsters like pick you up I feel like
they do way less than you damage that
should yeah yeah it must be like me
being used to Dark Souls as I had
mentioned before that's like up when
they scooped you you generally die
oh he's limping time to capture just run
in front of him he's a real slow boy -
I'm down - dude do a straight murder oh
you got a straight murder
alright I need you I need to get those
those murder points those murder carbs
oh great tracker it's like what are you
going oh hey - it's not full only have
five people thanks blacks are change the
DNS I could try that I haven't tried
that I guess no I don't feel like I
should have to although yeah oh my god I
walked away specifically to avoid that I
would try to change a DNS I don't think
I was gonna do anything but it's worth a
shot
- I was going all the way into his
little hiding area
yeah where he has his nap time
say either you the charger or greatsword
do it do a thing always I'll do a thing
or you just put some barrels down oh
we're going for capture anyway they
missed it someone's gotta wake him up
and make him walk on it up there you go
bomb him there is we got that returnee
gathering home he's he's a he's an
aggressive little dude but you still can
take him down let's see here I'm gonna
double-check this because I want to I
want to be sure about it yeah yep that's
exactly what I wanted to check
everything is that just as I thought it
was yep mm-hmm
imagine if you're just looking at your
logs and all of a sudden you just got
interrupted cuz that's the thing see oh
yeah you got it right isn't that little
bird brain looking things that this guy
yeah there we go double scalps yeah I
told you you could get it from capture
nice good good nice I like it yeah I
need scales though god dammit I still
need the gym I've only got one gym ever
that me and I try praying to to pickle
brick to get in Rick please yeah doesn't
it usually go faster than this like it
shouldn't be this party yeah it's it's
usually much much quicker than that I'm
gonna go in except some of these guild
cards receive yes
gimme then i'ma send mine to everyone
this is this is some chicanery here oh
do you do you want me to try to back out
and recruit now okay or sending you a
fresh invite yeah me said anyone even
though I don't see why that would work
also I don't understand why
the wee-fee isn't working the way I feel
like it should be so weapons are now the
medes they can be augmented twice making
them the most powerful weapons in
Tagaytay
well dingo know about that sir I'm not
up on the meta enough - it's a comment
on that because it's still only a tier 7
weapon it's not serious
imma imma be honest though DLC weapons
or additional weapons coming in after
the game being the most powerful in the
game sounds very par for the course yeah
yeah and that I'm pretty sure that's
what happened in the last two Monster
Hunter games that I played I know the
hunting horn for sure is a lot better
but I don't know buy anything else I'm
still really upset that I fell back onto
using this like collector's edition set
hey I told myself all the way through
I'm like I'm not gonna do it I'm not
gonna do it I'm gonna I did it do a
thing mm-hmm
try fighting that that pickle again I
need my gym we'll post this quest oh
actually I could try I'm gonna see if I
got an investigation because I saw
investigations pop up yeah you're pretty
I'm always positive you won't but prove
me wrong it's worth checking I'm into it
see do you just class or can you switch
them and get so it's not a class so much
as like whatever weapon you have
equipped changes what you do glad you
see yourself Raphael it's a good time
glad you got into the game that I can't
get it - oh no connection speeds are
estimates look at that connections
beyond nice it's a nice connection speed
jeez I find not strong in this room it's
got really really thick walls that's a
lot of invites from me see this is
taking up its load I kind of I finally
got that ps4 Pro and I realizing like
how how much I'm not into like
the extra load times and like even like
this slight visual bump that it gives to
most games with the boost mode and stuff
yeah like I miss it
investigations do we have any yeah we do
there's one right there for Rathalos
though I didn't look at sevens I guess I
only looked at sixes so nice so got it
wrong I got one with him in it I'm gonna
pick it up but I don't he sounds like an
intense fight it's the best weapon for
beginners personally I think that
longsword is a good choice because there
isn't much to kind of mess with outside
of keeping the weapon sharp and also
kind of lets you get an idea of how how
the combat works in the game dual blades
if you want something that's a little
fast err and more action gamey I feel
like those are probably the two best
bets oh also the the sword and shield
because you're in shield yeah like that
is the the default beginner weapon just
set because you get good offense and
good defense a little bit of everything
to kind of mess around with oh but don't
be afraid to try something else out if
it looks cool too you know it's
hilarious I feel like you've never had
problems playing with John Lee great I
think there was one time but it was when
there were server issues happening okay
maybe it's maybe there's another thing
going on so I don't think so either
all right let's post up that that
pickleboy quests do we want to do that
investigation I have one for a Dogo Dogo
guy mine GG oh nice oh x2 reward money
we're doing this one guys yeah gonna get
we're gonna get rich you broke that and
I got a lot of money I mean I got a
little money but I just you can never
not have enough money
because no you get down so honey real
fast with upgrades I'm gonna use this
alright
it's for answering your question any
time I'm happy to help anyone who's
who's curious about the game and want to
want to try things out wait they get in
did you are you I don't I'm mildly
confused right now I'll hold off before
we jump in to see no wait I mean wasn't
it it didn't give you an error no it
looked like I was in the world and then
it booted me back out to here no go
ahead
okay alright I'm almost positive it's
not going I'm ready for departure ready
I didn't they decrease loading times in
the update they probably did I'm sure
they've made some general like
performance stuff but like just
everything else with the pro is really
nice I really I feel good about that
purchase I feel better about my xbox 1x
purchase though so yeah that one's like
you do because they're they're updating
like 40 69 herbs flippin Forza horizon 1
skate 3 I didn't think that skate 3
could look like a game that came out now
just real weird almost a hunter came
with a voucher oh you know it does the
bow gun good for beginners it's there's
a lot to kind of wrap your head around
with it but if you watch a couple of
like videos on YouTube there are tons of
people like gaijin hunter and iraq's who
do really really good guides and I'm
sure that you could probably like if you
really want to do bow gun you could you
could do a bow gun this might take a
little bit extra work what's the best
elementals SNS I don't know enough about
sword and shield same alright failed to
join failed to join so I say we get a we
get the pickle first and then we'll move
on to the Rathalos easy go play by
myself here yeah let's go I got I got a
hunting
I just I got some deviljho these
connections are getting I ain't got time
for these which two looks really good
like that it's really interesting that
they're not only updating their the
current catalog but also the back
catalog to work with the new console
also like playing it was it the last
hitman game it it was probably the worst
on Xbox one
until the Xbox one X update hit and now
it's like almost on par with the PC
version it's real real wild you just ran
past them yep
grab this honey though what's the best
element and longsword
your along person I like fire but there
are a lot of things that use fire like
the blue blue rathalos swords one of my
favorites game Oh Cassie I don't think
it matters even if you just started that
you're watching the stream I mean sure
you're seeing a monster then maybe you
won't see you till later in the game but
it's not really that much spoiler I
guess especially what we're doing now
because you're not gonna see cuts in
during like that so yeah we're well out
of the story content there's not really
like spoilers that were tough right now
just keep slashing at each other
yeah so for the race I guess I just have
to make another session cuz at least the
first time it works you know what I mean
yeah yeah
I can totally get in the game yeah and
as Monster Dirac says there is no best
elemental because every type fits a
different type of monsters weakness yeah
it's like you wouldn't take a fire
longsword to go and fight a Rathalos
because their main thing is fire it's
all situational where you do what I do
with the switch axe and you just take
the highest base damage and call it a
day hey just take the the explosion mark
that's a lot everyone's weak explosion
all the time right now or not everyone's
weak to it everyone's susceptible to it
he's in a real awkward spot right now
yeah I don't I don't like it I don't
like it when he's in the hallway like a
little Holloway go crazy if we can get
him like lack started using a tiara
switch yeah heck yeah that's like some
blast cool look cool sometimes you just
gotta you gotta do that weird uppercut
with your sword oh yeah
I should see if I have any
investigations so I think the
investigations only come from when you
like break stuff I've definitely broken
some the stuff
yeah those new limited bounties are in I
think we might have both laugh at each
other or each other back yo I got a
triple I got a deviljho engine Anthon
rathalos oh dang that doesn't look like
fun the only one I have seems that way
oh that's unfortunate
hmm always going out to eat something
out here mm-hmm
the boy gets hungry soup yeah that's the
only one I have
oh if you're if you're your new and
jumping in
welcome to the Monster Hunter I'm glad
you decided to jump in I hope you enjoy
your stay and have a good time killing
monsters bring your friends with you I
definitely enjoyed mine so I hope you
enjoy yours
no I'm like oh no all I've got is that
like that half step when you're in your
sword form that's why having the kuchela
door alarm whereas pretty good whisper
checks yeah get that sweet evade
distance kind of can't live without it
now I did me honest there's so much good
like or you put the dams on that won't
see jumping games like just there's so
much good stuff you can do to augment
your character just mr. Smith says hey
Eric teh destiny to is 50% off on PC 75%
off by e3 poor Bungie oh they'll be fine
it'll definitely be fine you say that
you know 50% off great deal time to get
in new dlc probably in May there you go
yeah
right on his jaw oh right on my head
okay
nice glad you found someone to hunt with
gruesome gaming heck yeah I'm still got
240 plus yeah
pretty good that's it's a good a good
time love the game already addicted just
a lots taken yeah it there's a lot of
systems and things going on but I mean
if you're already enjoying the combat
and what it's like to hunt a monster
that's all you need all the other stuff
is nice extra has been maxing all that
stuff
finding the weapon that's good for you
or maybe multiple weapons multiple
weapons that armor sets and things like
that for those weapons yeah I think I
explosion yeah yeah I think my uh like
personally for me I'm not even like like
I can min/max a bit but like my favorite
part is I just like hunting the monsters
and I like playing with with pals
probably the most yeah
it's like I'll mix in a bit but my
character is probably never gonna be
like the best it can be like
statistically and that's something I can
totally love with Daniel Rivera asking
what's the best armor set for long story
I think it kind of depends oh he's dead
captain right out here in front of the
camp I didn't even see you guys tranq
bottom
you got nice I don't think there's
necessarily a best armor set I mean
there's are more configurations that'll
fit your playstyle you know are you
going for like a lot of damage a lot of
like affinity it's whichever one looks
the best because it's all about fashion
hunter that's true and and I think from
what I've heard a lot of people said
like in this game more than any game it
feels like you can kind of just do
fashion hunter because like it's not as
hard as it used to be this isn't the one
I wanted to go to but yeah I can't get
into this session ID feels bad yeah I
don't know why they're trying to keep us
apart I don't get it I know I don't know
I'm gonna delete my save data no don't
do it you've got so much hours actually
my fashion right now is
great but I'm here for the day my sets
about this sometimes you gotta put
fashion fashion hunter aside but you've
got them back don't mind me I'll just
play like blood-borne here on the side
or something it's a good way to do it
you know it's or I wonder if you turn
off you're an old skinny private thing
I'm just gonna grab this egg so I could
say well that's definitely coming unless
the girlfriend comes come on down uh
it's coming near right cuz I see or
notes below you right now yeah if you if
you run around with the egg enough I
know it'll come up waste of skin let's
go goop don't worry I already have a
safe level ten ready to go kill blood
start beast you know you how to do it
you know it's right down there that's
fine we can just run to it sketchy
gaming yo second stream in a row I
caught live I'm on a fire right now the
heck yeah oh look look who it is
it's the rathalos look who decided to
show up
oh that was an early pre-emptive
flashbang that did not work sometimes
you just got to do the early flashbang
yeah I wouldn't say the first time you
fight near your gat a it takes 40
minutes it can take some can take 40
minutes but if you go prepared
oh no yeah no that's good if he comes
this way it wasn't good for me cuz house
in the middle of drinking and I'll come
down flashbang um now's the time or the
waterfall is not gonna take them
anywhere if we knock them down here ass
I'm gonna take them anyway no no
I've killed maybe like three Rathalos
wrothians by doing that you can actually
kill them from it yeah look they just
fell down and Wow
I've had to just follow it hey like
didn't die it was just like I fell a far
away oh no and they're just laying on
the ground the best is when you can land
and still get a strike off yeah also
it's pretty remarkable that you don't
actually break your legs from it but you
know monsters got real strong real
strong thighs you know like whatever
monster hunters got real strong thighs
so just so everyone that's in the
session right now knows we'll probably
have to a bend in the session later for
the race and then make anyone that
people join so that I can get into it
cuz that's so far is the only way I'm
gonna do I shouldn't be grabbing this
one I'm grabbing this oh and I got laid
off of it yep worth killing it I think
Hugh key is just kind of you know
sharpening blade like what are you doing
over here yeah just gonna take all the
chances there we go
can't see John Cena
come back why are you running away from
me as it knows it's it's starting to
fear I'm hoping future DLCs bring even
tougher monsters like faith Vitalis with
endgame meta seems even temporary elders
you can steamroll in five to ten minutes
yeah I mean if you're really geared you
can steamroll the tempered elders not
they're not super hard and once we get
used to him like I don't know if that's
a good or bad thing but it also just
shows how much more skill you've gotten
as a player I feel like - yeah and or
just how you see yeah I mean like even
for me I kind of fell off I was doing a
bunch but then the whole grinding
decorations thing kind of got old for me
so it just there's not really a good way
of achieving that stuff like the stuff
you want cuz it's too orange erased but
I heard actually doing like the tier 2
investigations is actually faster than
like or more efficient than forming like
Elder Dragons because you'll kill the
stuff that's tier two faster
give them the element discharged right
up on his face doing big beeps and then
more deeps
beep Sandeep Sandeep I love how just
like into murdering a rathalos you can
get like it's it just becomes the thing
where you're not afraid of certain
things anymore that's kind of what it is
- I feel like so I still love fighting
Rathalos though like even even through
all the games that I fought it in like
it's it's just a fun fight it feels like
coming home you know I got another plate
nice today's just a plate day how do you
want to do this what do you want to do
here um
burly you want to start waiting for this
dream you know start your session up
well you want me to make a new one how
are you thinking of doing or should I
like sure I can do that so you like a
solo race oh so it doesn't include
people which is a thing but I feel like
just because everything is all kind of
busted yeah it might that would be the
way yep okay that seems that seems like
a smart idea and then we can finish I
feel I feel like the race is the high
point I think that oh you think so so
you want to do one more I think so I
mean I could I can fight this I got
another spray all day
you got another plate I can't believe
this why am I getting all these plates
actually didn't get as much double joe
stuff yeah but whatever what can you do
solo race team been big money
I appreciate that even even after the
embarrassment that happened last week
you're you're still down he has
continued faith it's mainly because he
doesn't think he just wants to bet
against me okay that's fair you know
I'll take it either way I'm not not
particular Lane Harrison I'm kind of in
the same similar boat I didn't really
ever get into the God of War Games but
the new one does look good and I think
I'm the also picking it up the combat
looks really good pretty good from what
I've seen definitely want to try it out
myself but it's a more seemed pretty
high on it so
so should I should I leave this you go
to like I don't know I could game by
myself I could just start up a thing
from here by myself anyway yeah let's do
a one person we deprecated at the same
time though I switch are you using that
axe really no all right do you want to
use it I'll use it to Carlin I'm gonna
double-check because then the are the
rest of it would be armor that we would
be someone thinking about bringing back
this boy the basil Ryder yeah I like I
like it a lot
yeah well I've kind of Bandhan it it's
up to you I mean I'll use this X if you
want to use it if not then I'm going
back to the old Diablo so use use
whatever you use I'm not not not feeling
feeling bad either way okay that's fair
if if I lose this time that's that's
fine if I win this time that's fine
now oh you're getting it ready dude you
have a button specifically for it oh of
course I have a button this is beautiful
is this of course I have a button I like
it and of course I have to have a button
there has to be a button it has to be
the like big red button the panic button
okay just give me give me some are we
just doing that optional probably yeah I
think that's the only one we can do all
right you guys didn't know last week we
did this thing where we did a race now
it was a team race last week that
involved other folks and I wish we could
do that we could try doing it so okay
here's one things I think we should do
we should do the solo race okay right
then I want you to back out make a new
session I'm gonna join that session okay
and then we're gonna both post quests
and then we're gonna try to do a team
race again and if that doesn't work then
that's fine
alright we'll do the solo race first
because we know that's gonna work yeah
that's the one thing we can we can count
now we can control this one whereas I
can't control the other one one person
are you eating before or after
before okay are you going I guess it's
whatever shadows we want it to be yeah I
mean yeah this is Street rules
thank you ma'am assuming you're
capturing it are you killing it is that
a thing cuz it up to you I mean
capturing you don't gotta take out that
last bit but what if we're in the zone
yeah so what do you want to do so you're
saying we have to kill you want to do
have to kill haven't said I'm asking I'm
asking for the I'm asking for all the
stipulations all right let's let's call
it a murder a murder a race to murder
you know yeah somebody can't necessarily
catch up from just what you might call
it oh my god attack ELLs only got ten
life whatever we got mega potions
charity you know if you're if you're
doing it right you don't even need it oh
look at you big guy I mean Here I am
talking here that I have everything I
need
scared of devil double Joe back in
Monster Hunter 3 dumped still kind of
scared to deviljho
to be honest no I don't have a chalk
trap but you know whatever I would just
take the tranq bombs out as to not even
be tempted Oh
t-rex really what I'd be into that if
they brought him back I'm just on my
monsters that would come back alright
before we get started who put your Benz
and Erickson chat for who you think will
win the race to kill the pickled guy
that I can't seem to point to he's right
there
first all right let's see random pick
Eric all right that's fair random is
better than not yeah get your bets in I
want to see them I know that chats like
30 seconds we get up the departure
window just to just to be ready okay
like that yeah also you're only gonna
get Ben's audio and not mine you'll see
my picture mines to the road it's all we
know left of me
yeah but you
his audio which is what is important Wow
there's only there's not too many bets
coming in oh wait there they are
she team been money on York I like that
answer that's a good answer
what is this I mean there's neutral
asked comments here this supposed to be
like there's some some good some good
old girls stuff going on like what you
might call it guy why do I forget salty
bets oh we should get like a monster
race oh here we go that's what I want to
see team bans good Kuroko is all myself
you guys are too too good to me for
still believing and I ban you say when
all right you ready all right three hold
on we're going on on one okay said I had
to catch myself I was asked to all right
three two one oh no I was a second
behind we had it in sync last time yeah
it was it was pretty on last time I have
a bad feeling I'm not gonna be able to
find him right away
Oh watch what's gonna happen I'm because
I did a whole bunch of researching it's
gonna drop me on top of him and I'm
still gonna lose I know I'm calling it
right now one of us is gonna have our
our character not dropped in camp at the
camp oh don't say that in which case we
both abandoned we've all depended on
retry for for a hundred percent fairness
or I'm a cam I am a cam - we did it luck
to you sir good luck to you as well
all right okay oh you're not mm-hmm oh I
could lose this race just back of
knowledge I don't know of where mr.
deviljho is gonna be you've you've got
that like you've got that min/max
knowledge like you've got all your stuff
so he doesn't show up here all the time
is a problem I'm pretty sure you're
gonna find him first I think this is the
only way I can kind of get a little bit
of an oh I got one old footprint that
doesn't really help me though oh you
don't even have the trail yet I owe you
don't have the trail I had the trail I
could shoot you were hunting him before
I have hunted him a lot of times did you
not go to the the dude who update your
book no oh that would do it
now let's what's that all about what is
what is this it's that's not it's not a
tackle there is no it's okay fine that's
fine I'm just gonna keep looking for him
randomly like an idiot no you got this
you can do the tracking nah dude I
believe in you didn't even give me the
next set of footprints it's fine it's
gonna be fine guys this is really if you
can change your bets you should really
change your bets to Ben right now I
don't know
God he's just murdering everything yeah
at least you're fighting him yeah that's
true
I don't even know where he's at I'm just
gonna go to where I know he usually
shows up the major upset though is does
a comeback catch up to me with a scumbag
capture oh no no not gonna be that look
it's a great cat spraying it's another
great Jagger's footprint she's just
sitting there holding onto that thing in
his mouth that's a great Jagger's thing
oh I finally got the trait is that
leading me to the [ __ ] great Jagger's
feels bad guys
I failed you all
I can't tell if this is leading me to
the great joggers feel like it is I feel
like I got hosed out of here
no don't get poison you at some point
I'll feel the same type of terror that
you're feeling my plan backfired on me
real hard taking me this way please
don't okay still following the trail I
swear to God I got an investigation
that's always good nice nice
oh are you have you been out here this
whole time
nope oh don't worry I'm still tracking
him I'm still tracking him been here I
figured by the end of the stream all I
would have done oh he's right oh [ __ ]
he's right there though he's not right
there but he's on the matter and I found
him he's on the goddamn map now you know
we're you but he's so frickin far away
is he oh he's far he's far right now
don't worry guys eric has the skills to
keep up thanks black star I was gonna
say you've you've got the you got the
other skills to pay the bills yeah yeah
wait Oh which eyes faster no this ways
faster okay we found them we found on my
marsh aren't my stream guys don't worry
I finally get to engage in combat with
them don't worry everything's gonna be
okay oh my god I'm getting juggled right
now get out of town what is this
what are you doing concentration mode
we're behind right now
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
oh I just parrot oded myself I don't
have the skills to pay the bills so I'm
kidding I'm getting that that nervous
feeling we're both asleep right now
we're both taking a nap I'm really
feeling it you would think I would wake
up first how are you doing I'm I finally
mounted him after I got like tossed
around a whole bunch but I'm about to
die nob dude you're not gonna die
believing you come on why am i I
shouldn't be doing the tale focus I
should just be doing a damage focus I
actually I'm gonna be honest I can't
actually hear you that's fine this that
that's a okay son of a B oh that's not
good you chose poorly Kuroko I'm sorry
to everyone that bet on me I'm sorry
oh my guys running that's not good
mine's running too why would you run we
barely died barely did any damage to you
I'm still like trying to gather
materials that fall off of him though
cuz I like deep down I still want to
build like the set and everything okay
well at least he's in the next area we
just got to go all out this is where
like the saltybet you're like you're
like you bet on like Mexi Gohan or
something and you're just like salty
about the fact that like he does like a
shitload of damage or mspaint
oh oh you son of a B hi I would like to
hit you
no another mount get off get off there
get on the back
come on
go for another one do it again do it
again write the topic Adachi yeah that's
fine you danced with him for a little
bit oh no don't pick him up
hi just okay he's slapping me with the
topic Adachi
hello it's that's how he works you know
you're being a real big piece of crap
right now
I was materially around here but I can't
stop to look though it I can't I can't I
got it I got it take me there sick oh my
god how are you doing
nervous missing my jumps are gone
terribly on my screen nah I don't
believe that for a second I do just ran
away again perhaps he won't see me in
this sport puffs nope he saw me
come on
yeah we mounted them
come on good news guys we're still
behind Oh No what a waste
come on Mike hey he's in the same area I
met I think where the pooky-pook age
normally at yeah yeah whoo boy please
come on
I was a lucky mistake nope
bring it back down I would like that
bigger wasp thank you no no no don't run
at least he's poisoned come on don't I
be able to Tarzan my way there nope I'm
gonna run through the water like a scrub
that's nothing actually catching up I
don't I have I do probably are
I actually a hundred percent have no
idea if I'm actually catching up or not
Oh fight the topic Adachi do that yeah
slap him wait what the hell he literally
didn't want him and it did nothing
all right yeah he picked him up and he
hit me with a yard jerk
come back here stop stumbling around
you know you really shouldn't be
treating other monsters like that nope
I tried to slide into him that was a
mistake
a surprise that didn't hit me actually
been yeah oh you just threw him at me
out of the air again I am in such big
trouble big trouble please don't die you
know you two are they literally won't
let me drink a potion right now they're
books just like yelling at each other
monster talk she's running away oh he's
going back down the tunnel it's just
going back and forth
I've done like no damage to him maybe
outside of like one mount your eye for
like even I think oh yeah that would be
a good call if I actually had a goddamn
thing to shoot that rock with a scatter
nut red pit all right we're gonna try to
get him with the rocks guys I don't
think it's gonna work though oh please
what are you doing come on it hit his
goddamn tail come on she did not
register it I try to hit him with the
rocks and it didn't work the heck I got
hosed I got absolutely hosed
stop stop come on I'm getting eaten
again
I literally should have hit him with
those rocks his hitbox should be so
ginormous that anything [ __ ] out of
there what are you doing will you fall
over thank you I'll grab that honey cuz
I know I need it
I don't want to fight you here I kept I
on the rocks I'm looking I can totally
do the same thing they're not going so
well
dude same big same oh my god I'm gonna
call that I got really lucky there Ben
yeah
no don't run we're supposed to be
catching up
I think you've caught up to be honest
this boy is running so much Ben he's
doing the back-and-forth thing for you
to know oh my god don't throw me up
again what the heck oh he just jumped
off a ledge a ginormous ledge I'm gonna
die I don't know where I am dying would
help me a lot actually bad okay I don't
know if you need the help though I think
you're already caught up i legit need
all the help I can get
oh yeah are you gonna pick me up is he
doing it again
what the hell get out of here devil Joe
you're the worst
[Music]
what is even happening right now
are you are you really running again
he's like stop nope
he's running did you get him to limp at
least my god no this is bad
all right chopped his tail off though
that's pretty good
all right now it's not that time to
carve though no time for carving only
killing ah he's not limping for me yet I
fought him over so long the honey
respawned
oh come on well that was a big mess
oh he's limping away come back see I
don't even have him limping yet
don't run you're gonna make it so I
can't carve your tail you jerk are you
going you gotta stay here you're gonna
be a good boy and stay here oh I'm just
gonna car
[Music]
hit his feet dammit come back here
ow all he's limping at least but he's
running away oh damn these little jag
arrests get away from here way to see
he's gone to his sleepy place I think
same shoot you you straight up caught up
what's up you you like straight-up
caught up like I feel like he's actually
going in a sleepy place and he's going
really far which is kind of annoying
uh-huh my guy's tired he's really out of
breath don't jump off what are you doing
oh cool this is just what I needed a
basil oh god I was looking at your
screen and he tail-whipped me when I was
following him no oh my god
I have to climb all the way back up this
is horrible please don't run stay here
like a good boy God why would you even
do that I don't why is flipping why
would you run here just to oh he ran to
his hole like actual hole
he ran away from bagel goose I don't
have to deal with them I was trying to
get all clever and shock trap him so I
could do more damage and then he freakin
decided to run from my shock trap I
think he's down here come on don't
follow me down here stay away stay away
are you going to your sleepy place oh my
god oh you did it yeah good job I was
this is stupid oh you only got here if
look he finally came here if you if you
had you gonna be like you you would have
you would have gotten it I need to get
my cars before I forget
oh you do 12% 101 Eric what the [ __ ] I
know man
I let you down I let us all down the
only the only thing I was able is cuz I
got that research done that's the the
only reason I've got him before you it
was it was too much look these these
races are bad for my healthy a jerk
right now you know that uh I'm telling
you straight up wise or know tempered
Joe we're not sure it'd be real good if
there were though surprisingly has a lot
of health he does he's man we I had a
chance I had a chance there you know did
you imagine though like if I had lost
after I had that much of a lead like I'd
probably have to uninstall the game live
on the street I really can't I was gonna
be a shock trap him double mega bomb
catch-up win you know but hey I like it
I like that it's one one though
I'm very okay with that whoo
well whoo real close give you a little
scare
no you definitely did there was a point
in time where I forgot to breathe I had
to like a daddy not sure I was doing a
thing I haven't been carving deviljho
this whole time yeah I did the same
thing I'm like oh my god ha ha I'm the
reason so you're the actual winner real
winner of the whole thing the real
winner here
I got a gem I still don't have a gem
that feels fine with me this is a ok
this is a okay
rematch two out of three no we're gonna
try the we're gonna try the Group one
now should I stay in in my session you
want to try getting in here first and
then we'll try to remake it if it
doesn't work man he did not give him
very much it from killing him though
they're all I'll send you an invite
whenever you get out of there he had two
mounts three times Joe pinned him he
made him a limp and no brakes limp is a
different category than brake there we
go yeah Ted you would have won if if you
had had the tracking down like that
I shouldn't have won in that your actual
like killing time was much shorter than
mine but yeah thank you
it would have been closed still cuz it
still took me a good 30 to 45 seconds to
a minute there at the end to actually
kill him
oh that Wiggly hat I love it so much oh
look at Sauron ah the oh you sent me a
new one yeah this is a new one though is
this the old one it's the old one and if
that doesn't work all I'll back out and
wool will make it okay a new deal one
mount one break he towed it himself and
limped him towed it himself true oh I
did towed myself it's like I didn't mean
to sweep that guy oh you know what I'm
gonna just lost that gem no you're good
I think it auto saves after every hunt
anyway
yeah whatever I'm just I'm still trying
to like refocus still trying to lace it
I was so when I cut off his tail is like
oh we're in a good position sure the
whole time kept running and like I
shouldn't have looked at Ben's screen I
got slapped off while climbing a couple
times that could have cost me I don't
think I'm gonna get in this game dude I
was I was real nervous I guess is it's
not gonna work when bagel goose popped
up though
that was not my favorite for those guys
that are in the actual yeah the session
we're gonna have to make a new one so
apologies we're gonna do race number two
here at the group race where we either
go to be to 3v3 or something so what I
gotta do do I gotta go camera here are
you gonna make anyone are you gonna make
anyone it's gonna make a new one so I
got changed the session ID don't know
I think join in our change the session
ID sounds like a plan whoo goodness
can't believe it yeah all right I'm
gonna send you an invite this one
what's that Macari hello thanks for
stopping by yeah you can get in or try
to get in right now
although Cheryl oops I'll put the campi
right right put that new session ID uh
piss and you guys can can hit it up soon
I can't even get into this one it does
all kind of depend on that I should work
well that's already a bad sign that's a
big I think a big a plus movement like
it works for like one little thing and
then it like breaks everything yeah and
why you all right we're gonna do the
group the group race team Ben versus
team Eric assuming I get in but I feel
decent about this one I feel good about
it too
just cuz I didn't get this loading
screen previously so Phoenix spider
Sauron
whoever else that was in you're gonna
need to get into this new session ID
assuming Wayne doesn't fail right now
cuz it's just going through the Hot Tips
the forever spell right now you'll never
be lost again in this video game there
you go it says you joined okay that's
always good
all right we made it
everyone's getting in it's a good time
hooha Requip some stuff
every time any time I get worried about
anything I just think about how Wiggly
that hat is and then like I forget about
all of it you know it's it's all good
Blackstar I'm not I'm not ashamed why
what happen it's all good what he's
talking trash sees always okay he's
feeling it I like it
yes our arms in black stars in you can
put your money where your mouth is by
Phoenix is just watching this time okay
go up to the gathering hub they never
arm-wrestle you I don't think we ever
got to it I think we should probably do
that while they're joining she probably
won't ever watch again it's the arm
wrestles too much I still have some
trust left in our issue I didn't know I
could talk to the researcher and make
him show up
I just always go look for him like a
dumb hunter no dude that's that every
time you go hunt him is like the first
time and that's that's a real a real
benefit you know real high let's settle
this like real men all right you tap
circle just tap circles tap circle
what what happened
we're - sha-booyah each other yeah we're
too even too strong I can't believe this
ah oh thank you crime I appreciate it
it should be try like again yeah it's
like I feel like that's up we got guy no
I'll arm-wrestle you anyway this is fine
well we'll do we'll do another one I got
you there we go
good stuff all right back oh [ __ ]
everyone's just here we go gonna wear
him down
oh I got too excited started tapping
circle before all right Oh God here's
our aims of saving saving merit I gotta
like this is very important all right
yes you started doing as the shape he
was he was tired huh from his goodness
no man could be asked to arm-wrestle art
do we have eight people I think I think
we have enough people to post this up
alright let's do some ago posting a
double post up here we're gonna do the
team verse team action here well let's
go for I think we might be good for full
we'll see what we get I really hope
someone in my team actually has double
Joe already tracked should I go figure
that mess out uh you could go down and
talk to the dude I'd actually recommend
it it'd probably be better but you can
also he almost always spawns in the
second area hunter flambe are we doing
for yeah I just put four so you're
saying camp 11 or 1 what is the one in
the oh you don't have the other camp
yeah whatever I got I got to drop you in
there sometimes don't get it don't need
it don't it's not even a thing don't
need it I will go downstairs though to
uh let's go get that tracking yeah it's
good cool oh wait I can't rip oh no
whatever doesn't matter you know where
he pops up though I don't but I'm sure
my squad will my squad like girl they're
all on top likes to catch up from they
like to play catch up from behind here I
got two so you need one more oh I got oh
I got everyone baby woof
I got a full squad Ben needs at least
two more do we even have two more I
don't know I don't or one of my guys
needs to swore oh there would be Shawn
ik oh there we go are we short one are
we
I think we're short one hey so one inch
at na v Phoenix
we need us for it's someone anyone we
legitimately need a fourth dang dang
surely did it did it count
where's John Luke he's got to be done by
now right join team Ben - there you go
if it comes down to it I'm
down - I'm down to go I believe in our
Eevee for that's a very obvious
advantage there we go we're good okay
you got sour on all right I'm gonna go
eat real quick same actually that would
be a very good thing to do I'm gonna eat
you gotta eat
definitely gotta eat here it's pretty Oh
what is this you sat down for a
delicious meal and got LAN disconnected
hold onto brie invite you I'm gonna get
you back in here I'm so sad on multiple
levels right now we're gonna fix this
you know when we thought we just had it
and then everything just crumbled
everyone of us shot the bed here yeah
I'm very upset right now cuz we were
everything was good you know everything
was ready we were there it was it was
set actually I should take this new
Orion blade huh it's not a dumb question
Wayne it's all good
oh yeah this this is a this is a sign to
go and get that research yeah probably
on your way but this is a bad sign right
here yeah we took too long arm wrestling
we shouldn't have done the arm wrestling
shouldn't guys we might have to make a
new room
I'm not even joking what when you got
first disconnected it was still when we
were in the hub right it wasn't when we
were actually hunting yeah I was in the
hub was fine so we need to go we need to
get into the or I need to make a session
idea
yeah you try that you and then you don't
have to leave yours but then they would
have to join mine which would also leave
be equally annoying I guess to change
around the number again I can't believe
this why can't things just work it's too
much to ask no I don't want to damn it I
just messed this up yeah
dang I don't know what happened your
Sauron well I I assume that people are
just backing out because we probably
gonna have to reassemble everything
anyway well how do you want to do this
you want to separate I say a good move
might be to have you try to make one
okay and then I'll join up on that and
then we can you try changing the the
number in the room you think do you
think one more time or you want to do it
keep keep going
I don't know I mean which we try one
more time damn you I'm gonna make one or
like I said you can keep yours and then
I'll make one and then have people join
that one right to do that to just show
your screen enough do you just do
anything here I do private yes because I
don't want randoms jumping in yeah and
that that's the only thing yeah I'll
give you guys that session ID in a
second you can just switch over to your
thing and have it up in the display yes
yeah there you go just gonna make it
maybe a little bigger but well that's
the wrong session ID oh no that's fine
we're good look at that for now yeah for
some reason I thought everything was I
don't know what I'm thinking
it's Friday yeah I know I feel it's it's
flippin Friday cuz I don't like
microtransactions but I'm so tempted to
buy skin no black spiders switch sides I
like it all right yeah just gonna give a
time before everyone gets a chance to
actually be able to jump in biter I
almost bought the chef's one but I've
got the four outfits so like I'm set all
I need is Gilda marm everything's fine
apparently he's found in five and six I
don't know ocean man says devil Joe is
found in area five and six
sounds about right I think I'm not
that's the downside to having everything
connected I don't get press start and go
to player lists over one more yeah it's
that right there
so what are you doing are you all my
granya or am I just having three people
Joe whoever wants to go and join tastes
I'd hop on over I go talk to that
researcher where the hell is this
research it's over over that way on the
books yeah there he is oh you can't talk
to him until the things gone
curses foiled again it's more like
appreciation for the game they made
about a few emotes I I bought a few so I
could show them off also I'll support it
like I want I want more Monster Hunter
and that's not like yeah it's not a
secret thing I need three people alright
the one left you've got one you've got
some people coming in they're on their
way
you know if we give them enough through
buying like silly hadouken emotes maybe
they'll keep giving us cool cool
monsters and all that I'm down press the
triangle really quick you got one in
there don't have masters we'll be able
to watch the stream is said heck yeah
man heck yeah ocean man yep do it get
that thing Sauron is he still in there I
think he left I think I saw that I got
one maybe I just need one more of those
then we could 3b3 like last time there
we go
I'm gonna quickly do this research chat
thing you haven't talked to him yeah
yeah thanks but I don't talk to him in a
while what is all that
yeah it's only have one so might need
one of those guys to pop out I think
your subway
black star leaves they might be on the
way to you too okay unless we've got
people having connection issues I'm sure
they way they said something in chat by
now oh wait nope there you go got your
mix too
a plus team right here we go all right I
think I think we're spiders I was on my
team last time and so was I forget the
other one I have to look back at the
watt here I'll meet you guys at the I'm
scared to go to the gathering huh but
whatever all right
Oh what happened another product spider
withdrew but he's coming back okay well
he's at the table so I'm assuming I'm
coming to help yeah there you go
we can go to this thing can't we
oh yeah the so so proud of this it's a
very good setup Hey
could be better I mean yeah obviously
put it it looks good though it's it's
serviceable we know what we're fighting
we know who we are and we know what
we're playing that's that's true those
are all there all those factual things
they're optional I'm gonna one cuz I
don't have that thing I believe in us so
valid one this one's pretty good she get
that like backtrack area so still Slevin
gotten that rejoin black spider you
gotta you got to take that take this l
join my team whoa why would you tell him
it was an L already got my guys getting
ready here and then you come out of
nowhere and you're like blam here we are
there he goes there he goes all right
I'm waiting for my other two guys here
to get there there's one more now we're
just waiting for RI cool he's prepping
are gonna eat real quick yep mm-hmm
I'm eating did you eat yet oh yeah I'm
still late from the first time don't
give me that DC I swear to God Capcom
you're making it you're making it this
is I work together all right so he's
ready to go when Black Star I'm all
wound up and ready when
every year loaded up and ready this is
for the pride of the Internet guys I
need you at your s rank level here not
even a rank s rank you get that triple s
rank all right two of t y'all are ready
to go there's one alright so now I hit
so hit the hit the touchpad and then
alright I think we're good I ready
alright three two one oh that was just a
practice and now we're really ready
three two one
yeah that's 100% nailed it alright very
good put your bets in team Eric team Ben
here we go
we got four on fours alright I'd say no
matter no matter what happened I don't
even have a good I'm gonna forget to
breathe I'd also these guys I'm not even
close to him I got to follow my team
like he's probably gonna get there
before me
that's all sorry to my team I'm also
sorry to my team ooh black starts going
super saiyan 12 i gotta activate my
ultra instinct ha so I'm not even I'm
not even in the game yet and I'm already
like feeling it come on game load up
there you go time to go G ranked before
before it ever hits the game this is the
real G rank
oh I load it in from what is because I
didn't to camp no this is already going
off horrific Lee alright whatever we're
just gonna chase him we're just gonna
chase him from where we're at f it Yolo
I'll meet you guys there's he's in like
the back corner
let's do it I don't think that was the
right decision what I just did but
whatever Oh Black Stars here oh I hear
people fighting already
oh oh you're fighting them already Oh
shenanigans Ben do this this is this but
we get to free mount maybe here ooh come
on
Oh where'd the hell did he go no why did
he run oh he is not in a good place
oh he looks bugged right now like bugs
bugs are like bug like with bugs just
looked like he was running in place this
would not have happened if I equipped
the right mantle oh there we go oh he's
down get him boys he's down
go ham on him
mess him up just climb the place we
couldn't climb that's fine she keep
doing a devil Joe do that thing he's
cheating
[Music]
look our our loadouts we all got here
this is this is good
the devil is always sword long sword
looks pretty sick yeah it's pretty good
I was diggin it I want to get the the
fully upgraded version of it Rocksteady
it is Oh who's got a rock for this Oh
you're fighting him in a completely
different area then no we used it and he
didn't fall on it rip in pepperonis it's
all good
what is even happening what is low oh
that was some explosions ye yeah here
with that do this really fast a vine
trapped
dun-dun-dun oh I thought that was gonna
get me a mountain you guys mad at him
yet you don't need to answer that
Oh
oh there we go get him a second time
another another good ol rodeo
oh that hurt what more of the okay I
didn't bring max potions with me that's
fine back down oh nice good work the one
yiiikes
Oh
I just realized I'm not even at max
health what am i doing
what am i double doing come on
I was dumb
now look it's a coup yaku it's perfect
he's just bringing his egg along like a
yeah I'm hearing I got my egg guys
what's going on oh crap I missed the
ropes again just looking at chat you
shouldn't be doing that right now we're
in a race I don't know why I wasn't a
chat it's it's an instinct I've had to
remind myself to not do it a whole bunch
too just like ah man I need to see where
all my pals are at what are they talking
about
I got stay focus
yep saw that coming yeah come on back no
come on
oh he's down but he's in poison what
yeah nice flash
oh my god why am I missing so much your
head in the game
whoa you're like jumped up in the air
fell down Oh his tail came out though he
turned just in time not get that flash
come on is he is he hurt enough to go
back to his no he's not
oh he's tired boys he's tired he's going
to sleep
remember no capture right this is a kill
this it's a murder murder time oh boy No
Oh No uh okay something else broke hit
him don't don't do it a cap yeah behind
you to sharpen my sword
this is no I ran
oh he's hurt so bad I'm just kind of
follow my guys nice come on where are
you where are you going there we go
don't let him run
now this is podracing that's too good
great jaga us ran away so fast earth
coming to party
yeah
yeah we did it oh yeah boys
we're so close he keeps running though I
know that feeling
yeah we won good stuff though we did it
quickly run back to where the tail is no
hell's his tail do that thing get that
get that get that charge charge blade
hit I believe in you
yeah where the hell is the tail you see
where I'd say that was it was kind of
close but guys you guys got him got him
a bit sooner it was a very good race
I liked it oh it's back the other way
now I know there's no way you know the
best thing about not knocking the tail
off and somebody don't have to run back
and get this there's no way it's too far
I can't get to it
how it was - we really got lucky because
there's one time he's like on the way to
run and we were able to kind of like
stop him but you got you're in a good
job we all shot flashes like so much I
only had one flashbang I didn't come as
prepared as I would have liked to but
it's right there will be future racing
there will be future races I really like
this it's a really fun thing like you
said it's like the pinnacle your ramp
yeah you know like we start off kind of
warming up then you kind of you bring it
in get the bring the heat you know get
those events going and then you get a
race at the end yeah that's pretty good
stuff into one and tazed lead that's a
really cool finish screen though oh you
got a tail though I did get a tail even
though we didn't knock it off yeah mine
is not so great my sword is just kind of
up in the air I still don't have a gym
oh yeah
so at least in that regard I want that
one it's very true and I did show up I
was rodeo rodeo but I did not show up I
got carried I got put in a backpack you
know that would be interesting thing to
group groups and solo races keep them
keeping
separate leagues yeah definitely kind of
that thing we could expand it out
yeah when when you do a solo and a group
one right when monster monster hunting
racing makes it to eSports and we get
that big eSports money from it that's
that's one will know we have to do we'll
need some sponsorship from like G fuel
and get all those cool cool dudes in
there to do it but I really appreciate
all the guys that came hung out to watch
yeah and also you know join us in the
race to hunt along we'll play to you on
the solo Scylla race that's great job
good times yeah yeah we'll be back of
course next week every day we stream at
11 a.m. sometimes earlier depending on
you know if we have something early
obviously like we had far cry 5 today 10
a.m. was the embargo so we went a little
earlier but what's up Richard there's
your shoutout looking good Richard but
yeah next week I'm sure we'll die back
into FarCry again as you know we won't
have any NDA's anymore for that on
release day which is 27 maybe we'll dive
back into that dead game destiny to
because they're actually getting a big
update there you go I think that's worth
checking out we'll see maybe of course
Monster Hunter we'll be back next week
John Luke will probably be here so
you'll have to race with him a long time
and then I'm trying to think what else I
owe Dragon Ball Fighters oh you'll see I
think is out next week so Brawley bårdek
will be streaming that ones day I think
so
stay tuned all that 11 a.m. if you
haven't subscribed do that thing as we
go live on YouTube but also we do cool
features and I think the new potato mode
went up already it did it's very good
it's a today was can we come deliver
check that out and yeah any last words
been like always keep it cool stay in
school count those monsters be real cool
and nice to everyone good luck with
deviljho hope you guys get gems and all
the stuff you need later bye